we're told that we want to factor the
following expression and they ask us
which pattern can we use to factor the
expression and u and v are either
constant integers or single variable
expressions
so we'll do this one together and then
we'll have a few more examples where
i'll encourage you to pause the video
so when they're talking about patterns
they're really saying hey can we say
that some of these can generally form a
pattern that matches what we have here
and then we can use that pattern to
factor it into one of these forms what
do i mean by that well let's just
imagine something like u plus v
squared we've squared binomials in the
past this is going to be equal to u
squared
plus 2 times the product of these terms
so 2 u
v
and then plus v squared
now when you look at this polynomial
right over here it actually has this
form if you look at it carefully how
could it have this form well if we view
u squared as 9x to the 8th then that
means that u
is and let me write it as a capital u u
is equal to
3
x to the fourth because notice if you
square this you're going to get 9x to
the 8th so this right over here is u
squared
and if we said that v squared is equal
to y squared
so if this is capital v squared then
that means that v
is equal to y
and then this would have to be 2 times
uv is it
well see if i multiply u times v i get
3x to the 4th y and then 2
times that is indeed 6x to the 4th y so
this right over here is 2 uv
so notice this polynomial this higher
degree polynomial can be expressed in
this pattern which means it can be
factored this way
so when they say which pattern can we
use to factor this expression well i
would use the pattern for u plus v
squared so i would go with that choice
right over there
let's do a few more examples
so here once again we're told the same
thing we're given a different expression
and they're asked they're asking us what
pattern can we use to factor the
expression
so i have these three terms here it
looks like maybe i could use i can see a
perfect square here let's see if that
works if this is
u squared
if this is u squared then that means
that u is going to be equal to 2
x to the third power
and if this
is v
squared then that means that v is equal
to 5.
now is this equal to 2 times uv
let's see 2 times uv
would be equal to well you're not going
to have any y in it so this is not going
to be two u v so this actually is not
fitting the perfect square pattern so we
could rule this out
and b both of these are perfect squares
of some form one just has a i guess you
say adding v the other one is
subtracting v
this right over here if i were to
multiply this out this is going to be
equal to this is a difference of squares
and we've seen this before this is u
squared minus v squared so you wouldn't
have a three term polynomial like that
so we could rule that one out so i would
pick that we can't use any of the
patterns
let's do yet another example
and i encourage you pause the video and
see if you can work this one out on your
own
so the same idea they want to factor the
following expression
and this one essentially has two terms
we have a term here and we have a term
here
they are both they both look like they
are the square of something and we have
a difference of squares so this is
making me feel pretty good about this
pattern but let's see if that works out
remember u plus v times u minus v is
equal to u squared minus v squared
so if this is equal to
u squared then that means that capital u
is equal to 6 x x 6 x squared that works
and if this is equal to v squared well
that means that v is equal to y plus 3.
so this is fitting this pattern right
over here and they're just asking us to
say what pattern can we use to factor
the expression they're not asking us to
actually factor it so we'll just pick
this choice but once you identify the
pattern it's actually pretty
straightforward to factor it because if
you say this is just going to factor
into u plus v times u minus v
well u
plus v is going to be six x squared plus
v plus y plus three
times u minus v u is six x squared
minus v is minus we could write minus y
plus 3 or we could distribute the
negative sign but either way this might
make it a little bit clearer what we
just did we use the pattern to factor
this higher degree polynomial which is
essentially just a difference of squares
let's do one last example
so here once again we want to factor an
expression which pattern can we use
pause the video
all right so
we have two terms here so it looks like
it might be a difference of squares if
we set u is equal to 7 then this would
be u
u squared
but then what can we square to get 10 x
to the third power remember we want to
have integer exponents here and the
square root of 10x to the third power if
i were to take the square root of 10x to
the third power it'd be something
a little bit involved like the square
root of 10 times
x times the square root of x to the
third power and i'm not going to get an
integer exponent here so it doesn't look
like i can express this as v squared so
i would go with that we can't use any of
the patterns and we're done